all right you buy your buddy Chris yes
yes sir we're attached here you know
what see I always wish I could bring my
besties to these things because it makes
more fun doesn't it so much more fun I
hate doing this stuff alone so this now
it's like a party I know so who are you
trying to sneak a selfie with in there
everyone else I walked in Niecy Nash was
already taking pics and I was like oh I
love business hey I scream I don't hold
back no you do not yeah made you look is
that that song okay I mean isn't it kind
of amazing to see what the fans make of
it and how they turn it into something
completely else yeah I mean yeah it's
all it's more than I could ever ask for
and it's all because Chris Olson no
helped me get viral on Tick Tock because
she writes amazing music and everyone
needs to hear it all the time it's like
if Meghan Trainor's putting a song out I
already know it's going to be catchy and
stuck in my head exactly right yeah
sounds amazing yeah thank you I mean
after all these years what inspires you
these days in your work the young yeah
you know um
I'm like yo two dogs in to eat this up
like I truly
um am focused on like my fans on Tick
Tock but I also noticed that there's a
lot of moms out there I'm a new mama so
I'm like oh I didn't even know this
whole world existed so I just have a lot
more friends on Tick Tock and like
that's my home and I'm ready for two
talk well also you're writing for your
fans and because you really create these
self-love anthems like what advice do
you have for those fellow moms out there
who are still feeling like they're
trying to get their sexy back after
giving birth mamas it's coming
um just try to be easy on yourself the
mom guilt Can Eat You Alive and that
almost happened to me but I worked
really hard on forgiveness and
um yeah yeah that's be easy on yourself
JoJo siwa said you two have been working
on something what what is that something
we've been writing a few little Tunes
here and there she's a superstar and I
know she's working on her music her
future music she's all grown up now and
she has so much more to say
um and I was like please let me be a
part of it and she did so we got bangers
coming
[Music]